yeah yeah stamos so handsome
oh yeah really uh well i'd kiss him
really ah yeah
i would like to see him naked really i
don't know if i'd touch his dong but uh
i would cuddle with them yeah you
wouldn't cuddle with stamos
take the little spoon on that one that i
don't want to be the little spoon i'll
take little i'm submitting he's uh
i'm all in that he's still got a full
head of hair his skin looks great he's
in shape like how does he do it he said
he looks like rob lowe there's a couple
white guys out there who just hang in
yeah brad pitt looks great
crews rich dudes who have had work done
and have personal trainers oh is there
work done they've got to have there's no
way they haven't had work done trainers
i'll give you but
i don't know pull up if you pull up
stamos in 1994 to 2020. i'll give you
another one uh what's his name from uh
ant-man
rudd yeah rudd is like rudd is older
than the guys in cocoon were by the way
look at that
just tall dark and handsome hot cuppa
jizz he looks better now
wait a minute better than this
yes well it's only because the mullet
though he's he's a good looking younger
guy he's a little more rugged now like
there is a little kind of
i don't want to say chubby cherubic face
but now he looks a little more you don't
like young men you want a sugar daddy
yeah hell yeah definitely give me like a
he's a handsome guy
man with the suit with the eyes he's got
that the eyebrows
look at that hair not a [ __ ]
gray in sight
i'm sure he dies it but
unbelievable and guys who shave don't
always look great he's fully clean
shaved looks amazing
i don't either what do you think he's
into
sexually yeah
ah feta
[Music]
he goes have mercy